(electronic baby cries)
- Throw me the diaper!
- If this is anything like Tamagotchis,
I had like three, and
they died within a day.
- Robo-babies.
- It's not even a cyborg.
There's no human to love.
- Eugene and I are both very competitive,
so that means our baby
is going to be the best.
- I can't take care of myself.
- As long as I don't have to make
an emotional commitment to anything,
I should be good.
(electronic rock music)
- So today we got robot babies.
- We're having a baby.
This is exactly how I
pictured it would happen.
(electronic baby cries)
- It's basically a robot baby.
It's used in schools.
It's used in health classes
to teach baby curriculum.
- You have to change its
diapers, you have to feed it,
you have to burp it, you have to rock it.
- You have to change its diaper?
- How do you change a robot's diaper?
- So, this is like birth right now.
- This is birth.
(singing wordlessly)
- He's Asian!
- Baby, get out!
It's not alive, yet, right?
I'm allowed to mishandle it?
- Sploosh!
- Now my turn!
- Oh, definitely an Asian baby.
- Who does he look more like?
- Haven't you always,
I thought every white person
wants an Asian baby, right?
- He has blue eyes.
He gets those from me.
- He's also tiny, sorta like you.
- Yeah.
- Look how much hair he has!
Just like his father.
- I can hear something rocking in it.
- That's probably its censor
of "I'm being abused!"
- We have to name the baby.
- Yeah.
- I think it's important for a name
to have something of significance.
- I'm thinking Maurice.
- [Ned] JJ.
- [Eugene] JJ.
- [Ned] JJ. JJ Fang.
- [Eugene] JJ Fang.
- Maurice Kornsberger.
- [Eugene] You are so badass!
- [Ned] That's a dope name!
(chanting from "Circle of Life")
- I would be scared of this
baby if I was another baby.
- Let's bring our baby to life.
(humming)
- In three, two--
- Does it move?
Doesn't seem like it's--
(electronic chiming)
- Oh, it's the--
(electronic baby coo)
Yes?
- Hi, Maurice! Welcome!
- [Eugene] Hi, JJ!
- [Ned] Hi, JJ!
(electronic baby cooing)
- What do you want?
What does he want?
- How do you know?
They just cry
and you have to guess.
- [Eugene] Get the bottle Ned!
- [Zach] Do I just, do I just--
(electronic baby cries)
Hey, buddy.
(louder electronic baby cries)
- [Ned] No no no no no no!
- [Eugene] It's all right.
- Do I just stab it at its face?
- Just hold it to him.
(electronic sucking)
- How do I know when
I've fed him too much?
- He'll (beep)-ing let you know.
(happy electronic baby cooing)
- I'm done!
- Oh, what an adorable squeal!
- Do we have to burp him?
- Is that what we're doing?
How do we know he needs to burp right now?
He's just going, "Uhh."
- This seems excessive.
You're burping him for a long time.
- You burp babies for a long time.
- Let me try. Let me try.
- I swear to God I'm
gonna be better at this.
(electronic baby burp)
- [Ned] Aww, he burped.
- [Eugene] Aww, he burped.
- It sounded kind of like a fart, but...
Diaper change!
- That felt like a poopy!
(electronic baby crying)
- I know, I know!
- Come on!
(electronic baby crying)
- (beep)-ing put the diaper on him, Zach!
- No, he doesn't want it.
- I'm sorry, I was laughing at his penis.
- Don't laugh at his penis.
- His penis is hilarious.
How can you not laugh at it?
Stop crying, please!
(silence)
That was it. He just...
That was it?
- Is he dead? Did you kill it?
- He's not dead, right?
- Wait, we didn't...
(electronic chiming)
(relieved sighing)
Oh, thank---
(electronic baby coo)
- [Zach] Oh, he's happy!
- [Keith] "I'm happy!"
(rejoiced yelling)
- So, tonight we're gonna
take our babies home.
- It's gonna record our results.
- At the end of the night,
the baby's going to generate a report.
- And we're gonna stay up all night
trying to take care of the babies.
- Well, you know, we're gonna try
and get a good night's sleep.
- I don't think that's gonna happen.
- I, just this moment, had a realization
of how hellish the next
24 hours are gonna be.
(dramatic crescendo)
- What happened last night...
(loud electronic baby crying)
(intermingled talking and yelling)
- I guess we should
start at the beginning.
- Start at the beginning.
- We left the office very
excited, full of energy.
I thought, "Keith and
I having a sleepover?
"That's gonna be a fun time."
- He's a cutie pie.
You're gonna realize he's cute
and we're in charge of him.
- Ned's wife came for a visit
at the beginning of the night.
- That was so nice to
have some family help.
Once we had the baby down
to sleep, it was delightful!
- The thing is is that
you just kinda realize
that it's all worth it.
- [Ned] We did some work.
- [Eugene] We did some work.
- We're raising this baby both religions.
- We listened to classical music.
(classical music)
♫ Because you are JJ Fang,
- ♫ Better than Keith
- [Ned] ♫ Better than Keith
- [Eugene] ♫and Zach's baby!♫
- [Ned] ♫and Zach's baby!♫
- I didn't have a bar mitzvah,
but I do want Maurice to have one.
- We drank a nice Riesling.
- But you can't do anything to his dick.
- What are you talking about?
- And it was really pleasant.
- I already checked on that.
He's not circumcised yet.
- Of course not.
So, we get set to go to sleep.
- Maybe you strip Maurice,
and then I'll dress him back up again.
- Our baby's adorable.
- Dude, our baby looks amazing!
- We put our baby in the separate room
so it had its own nursery.
- [Keith] We figured
out how to make a bed.
- We'd snuggled him up in his blanket.
- [Keith] We say, "Goodnight."
- [Zach] Goodnight, Keith.
[Keith] Goodnight, Zach's phone.
- Goodnight, Zach.
- Goodnight, Keith.
- I think he might be
good the whole night.
- [Keith] You're crazy.
(dramatic crescendo)
(soft, creepy music)
- So (beep)-ing 1:30 in the morning--
- No, two.
- Was it two?
(electronic baby crying)
(dramatic classical music)
- He activated, and he just flipped.
(electronic baby crying)
(dramatic classical music)
- [Keith] I changed its diaper, nothing.
Nothing. Nothing.
- [Zach] Burp it. Nothing.
- [Keith] Bottle? Nothing!
- [Zach] Nothing!
- Sometimes, I was
like, "What do you want?
"What do you want?
"I don't know what he needs!"
- Baby screaming, scream, scream!
- It's gonna give us a bad score.
It's gonna tell us we're terrible parents.
- By the third time, it was more of a,
Can you do it?
- It's just a demon and it's
just banshee-screaming at us.
Did one of us do coke
during our pregnancy?
- I'd have to say the baby
was the source of the stress,
but the source of my anger was Ned.
Look, if this was a crib, you can't sleep
in the crib.
- [Ned] If this was a crib,
you can't sleep in the baby.
Don't even worry about it, bro.
- It's a nightmare.
- Can I just hold my child?
- And we're just up
forever, it seems like,
with this baby.
We just can't go back to bed.
- By the time the sun came out,
we were just over it.
(dramatic classical music ends)
- [Keith] I've gotta take a shower,
so Zach is gonna watch the baby.
That's what babies are sometimes.
I think how awful this thing
was was incredibly accurate.
- You really have to have teamwork
and patience with each other.
- [Zach] I feel like it brought us closer.
- It was less stressful with him than,
I can imagine, without him.
- It's a lot of work.
(vocal drum roll)
- [Voiceover] 79%
(impressed mumbling)
- [Keith] What is that, a C?
A C!
- [Zach] A C+!
That's pretty good!
- I'm unsatisfied with that, to be honest.
No mishandles? We didn't
(beep) up its neck?
I was sure I (beep)-ed
up its neck, I was sure.
- What did we get?
- [Voiceover] You got a 75.
(loud yelling)
- [Ned] That is ridiculous!
- [Zach] You just dropped your baby!
- [Ned] He's a robot!
He's not real!
- Dude, we did it! We're great parents!
- [Keith] We're great parents!
- [Zach] We're great parents!
(yelling gleefully)
- [Zach] You know what?
All this now, I don't
even care how tired I am.
I'm so elated that we did a great job.
- This is from the two guys who just said
they hated their baby five seconds ago.
- Yes, I did hate it five seconds ago.
Now that I'm a winner, I'm thrilled.
- Seeing your baby
laugh for the first time
would be just,
it would make everything that you did,
all of the late nights, just so worth it.